bonjour thomas lors le cortège est
arrivé à destination oui place de la
bastille le cortège est arrivé encore
des prises de parole mon nom je vous
parle notamment de la part de familles
des familles qui ont été touchés par des
drames qui les attribue pour certains à
des violences policières c'est tout le
débat justement ici avec notamment le
fait de pouvoir filmer c'est ce qui
revient très régulièrement dans les
discours parce qu'ils estiment qu'il ya
beaucoup d'affaires qui n'auraient pas
pu être médiatisé qui n'aura pas pu
aboutir
s'il n'y a pas eu de vidéos c'est donc
une des raisons pour lesquelles ils
s'opposent à cette loi sécurité globale
qui on le rappelle a été adopté au sénat
qui va maintenant retourner à
l'assemblée nationale malgré quelques
réécriture le corps encore de ce texte
de loi est toujours le même et c'est une
raison pour laquelle ici les
manifestants s'y opposer et parmi eux il
ya des forces des représentants de
forces politiques telles que la france
soumise on a pu interroger tout à
l'heure eric coquerel
le député de seine-saint-denis que je
propose d'écouter maintenant on a une
avalanche de mesures autoritaires
liberticide plusieurs puisque minatoires
qui sont prises il ya une sale ambiance
alors il ya la loi sécurité globale elle
va revenir à l'assemblée faut vraiment
se se battre coûte que coûte pour
qu'elle ne passe pas au moins qu'on n'a
rien à faire en sorte que l'article 24
si dangereuse ne passe pas mais toute la
loi est problématique et à la loi sur
les séparatismes
la loi seul article 24 et reprises sous
le titre d'article 18 dans la loi sur
les séparatistes puis au delà de ça il
ya une ambiance quoi je veux dire les
attaques de m vidal sur un soi-disant
islamo gauchistes qui permettrait une
chasse aux sorcières vous avez vu les
sorties la de monsieur blanc caire et
autres sur l'unef maintenant dont on
demande la dissolution l'unef simplement
pour avoir laisser organiser des groupes
de paroles interne entre personnes
discriminées
ce qui évidemment pas là et elle était
totalement
c'est totalement comment dire
disproportionnée les attaquer ce qu'on
subisse donc voilà il ya une mauvaise
hérite de ce gouvernement qui emprunte
de plus en plus finalement le discours
de l'extrême droite c'est ce qui
m'inquiète
voilà un cortège qui était composé donc
de plusieurs personnes qui
représentaient parfois les organisations
politiques syndicales ou encore
associatif dans le cadre donc de cette
journée internationale contre les
violences des forces de l'ordre et
contre le racisme manifestation qui
s'est bien déroulé qui a réuni plusieurs
milliers de personnes jusqu'ici donc
cette place de la bastille aucune
tension a dénombré lors de cette
manifestation il faut dire que le
dispositif de sécurité qui avaient été
déployés étaient très impressionnants
avec beaucoup de forces de l'ordre qui
sont d'ailleurs encore présente au
moment où je vous parle
et merci à thomas pour toutes ces
précisions